- We are back with Garth Brooks,
give it up, everybody!
(audience cheers)
Here about Garth working with
Dolly for the first time.
He's done this at such a
high level for so long,
we thought it'd be fun to
throw some random musical names
at him to see what his memories
and stories are with those people.
So here we go.
Good luck.
In honor of his residency,
Garth Brooks Plus One
that starts tonight at Caesar's Palace,
we are adding a Vegas twist.
You're welcome.
This is Rockstar Roulette.
(country music)
(audience cheers)
♪ Rockstar Roulette ♪
- I'll press this button
though and the roulette wheel
will spin, and whatever name pops up,
Garth has to tell a
story about that person.
Don't fail us, let's go.
- Oh my gosh.
- [Kelly] So here it is.
- [Garth] Who is it?
- [Kelly] I don't know.
(bell dings)
Ed Sheeran!
Do you like Ed Sheeran?
- Oh great, I love Ed Sheeran.
- (gasps) I love Ed Sheeran.
- I love Ed Sheeran, because you know,
when you talk about Vegas,
Garth Brooks in Vegas, right?
1400 seats, right?
- Yeah, it's great.
- It's awesome.
Ed Sheeran with just him
and a guitar, Croak Stadium,
86,000 people.
- [Kelly] I've seen him in an arena dome.
- Oh my god.
And it's just him in a guitar.
And what I love with him,
what I love is Ed has,
I don't even know how to explain this.
You don't have to reinvent music.
Okay, it's in the soul and it
just keeps getting recycled.
(guitar strums)
It's simple, right?
- [Kelly] Oh, I know that song.
- All the way back from, was it
♪ Oh my love ♪
- I love this song
♪ My darling ♪
Right.
- Yes.
- Exactly, so it could come move,
and it just keeps going
through the years, right.
Like,
♪ I heard about a secret chord ♪
♪ That David played and
it pleased the Lord ♪
♪ But you don't really
care for music do ya ♪
- Exactly.
- Jeff Buckey.
- Right.
- I mean Leonard Cohen.
- Come a little closer to
♪ I got a girl crush ♪
- Ah!
♪ I hate to admit it but ♪
♪ I got a heart rush
just won't slow down ♪
Right?
- Little Big Town, yeah.
- Do it, let's come all the
way up now to this, right.
Ed does it.
♪ I found a love ♪
- I love Perfect, that's
what got your way in color.
♪ For me ♪
♪ Darling just dive right
in and follow me lead ♪
♪ I met a girl ♪
- Simple storytelling.
♪ So beautiful and sweet ♪
♪ I never knew you were the
someone waiting for me ♪
- If I'm gonna sing the high part,
I'm gonna have to stand up,
so I'm gonna stop there.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
- You're right, though.
- It is.
- It's those timeless classic
kinda melodies and chords.
- Yeah, but it, that's
what I love about music.
It's timeless and it's
timely at the same time.
It just depends whose hands it's in.
Those four particular hands
when you talk about the songwriters.
- Storytellers.
- Woo!
Fabulous.
- I love that I said Buckley,
it was Leonard Cohen first,
the other song, but I was
like Hallelujah, yeah.
I knew it, I think, 'cause
of Buckley, but yeah.
Okay, we're gonna go next.
That was gorgeous, of course.
- Oh we gotta do it again?
- Yes, I'm gonna make
you keep, dance, monkey!
(Garth laughs)
Adele!
(audience cheers)
Who doesn't love Adele?
- Woo, this is tough.
- I love her.
- This is tough because the
story that comes to mind,
it's not a good one.
- Wait, what?
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, I'm so sorry.
My youngest, probably 12 years ago, 13,
my youngest came in from
school and she goes,
"Dad, dad, you've got to
hear this song from Adele.
"I've never heard a song like it."
I said, "Really?"
I said, what's it's name, says
"To Make You Feel My Love."
(audience laughs)
I said, "You have to
be kidding me, right?"
No, I didn't, I didn't say anything.
I said, "Oh really?
"Tell me about it."
(audience laughs)
People always ask, you know, well,
which is her favorite version?
I said, "I don't know, we
haven't spoke since that day."
(audience laughs)
But oh my God, when she, because you
♪ When the rain's blowing in your face ♪
- See, this is what I grew up on, yeah.
♪ And the whole world is on your case ♪
♪ I would offer you a warm embrace ♪
♪ To make you feel my love ♪
(audience cheers)
- Aw, I love that song.
- It's nice.
And I gotta tell you,
it's like anything that you cover right?
So it's like you, you're walking around,
going, Make You Feel My Love,
I feel pretty good about my version.
(Kelly laughs)
And then you hear Adele
singing, all of a sudden,
you're like, oh okay, I get it.
That she just, everything
she touches just sings,
it's beautiful.
- But also it's, yes, absolutely.
But also it's this sign
of such a great song.
So many people have covered this song,
whether they've recorded it for a version
or just done it for a show.
Like that's a great song.
And it's like, and it
depends on who's singing it.
Like I grew up with your version
and it's like one of
those things that just,
it hits me like in such a different way
than maybe when somebody else sings it
'cause of nostalgia, because
I'm a fan, like whatever.
But I think that's what's
so magical about music.
It has new life, like with other artists.
- Amen, and then let's talk
about the songwriter again.
That's Dylan, right?
And what Dylan is so great about it,
and what I'll try and do is
I'll try to impress you, right?
I'll try and go, oh, that's clever.
But Dylan just writes from there to here.
- It's very straightforward, yeah.
- Oh my God.
And it's so simple, it's not simple,
if that makes any sense, it's brilliant.
- Well, you have to be super
confident and comfortable
to keep it that like straight.
- Amen.
- And yeah, I agree.
- We're going again?
- Yes!
You're welcome.
(Garth laughs)
Oh boy, another one of your
daughters is embarrassed.
- Aerosmith!
- Aerosmith.
Now.
- Oh my gosh.
- I am a hu, I thought I was
gonna marry Steven Tyler.
(audience laughs)
I was like, ya ka ka ka ka kow!
Like all it took, everywhere.
I was like, I had a fan in my bedroom.
I was like, yes, I was, yeah
You gotta have a Aerosmith song.
- Oh, I showered with him.
- Oh wait, you covered the Fever.
- Yeah, we covered Fever.
- Yeah!
- But we were playing the last--
- Did you say, "I showered."
(audience laughs)
- I showered with him.
So we're playing the last
play at Shea, Billy Joel.
They're getting ready to
tear down Shea Stadium
in New York, and I go out
there and I'm late anyway,
and they have just the baseball showers,
and I'm in there showering and
getting ready for the show.
And I had soap in my
eyes, and look around,
and there's Steven Tyler,
he's showering too.
"Hey, how you doin'?"
(audience laughs)
And so it's just, it was, how
many people get to say that?
- Ah, no.
Well, who knows?
(audience laughs)
Who knows?
He's rock and roll, I don't know.
- Beautiful can at the end of the day.
- You might not be so special, Garth.
(audience laughs)
- But I just love him.
We were playing a writer's
night the other night
with Victoria Shaw and she
had a couple people get sick
and drop out and said, "Hey,
can you last minute pop on?"
I said, sure.
She was playing with a
guy named Mark Hudson.
So Mark wrote, Living On The Edge.
♪ Living on the edge ♪
- Oh my God, people, if you, right there,
when I said Living On The
Edge and you didn't go, "Ooh,"
that's because Living
On The Edge has the line
of all lines when you
talk about songwriters.
If you can judge a wise man
by the color of his skin,
then mister, you're a better man than I.
- Yeah, it's great writing.
- Oh, oh my God.
We wait our whole life to try
to write a line like that.
Right.
- Yeah.
- I just, I love his stuff.
But Aerosmith, yeah, we did Fever.
There's no way I could do Fever on here.
It's just a bunch of rah kind of stuff.
But it's--
- Which is incredible.
- He's unbelievable.
But anything he does--
- Anything you do though
right now is still not gonna,
we're all still thinking about you
and Steve and Tyler in the shower.
- Yeah, well, yeah.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, next one.
I love Aerosmith and I'm still thinking
of y'all in the shower.
Here we go, next one.
- That was three for three.
- [Kelly] I know, but
look, you're good at it.
- [Garth] What do we got?
Kiss.
- Ooh.
- I know you like Kiss.
- Kiss, so they had a tribute
album called Kiss My Ass.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Remember this tribute album?
- Yes.
And they said, "Do you wanna sing on it?"
And I said, well,
I'm thinking I'm the
only country guy on it.
'Cause in 1980 we had
an old boom in Oklahoma.
We talked about this in the Vegas show.
And all these guys moved in
from states that I never knew.
And some guys came down from Michigan
and they had the Kiss albums.
And we became best buddies.
And so I was like, yeah, I wanna sing.
I wanna sing either Detroit Rock City,
or you know,
♪ I wanna a rock and roll ♪
And they're like, "No, no."
- What?
- I was like, "No, really?"
I said just, I didn't wanna do Beth.
I mean, I'm sorry, but
if you're a Kiss fan,
Beth was the one ballad that they.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they let me do, what was it?
♪ If ever I'd met you ♪
♪ I'd never have seen you cry ♪
♪ If not for the first hello ♪
♪ We'd never have to say goodbye ♪
- Right, I got to do
♪ Rags ♪
♪ A sailors only daughter. ♪
And it was cool because the two Erics
were with them then,
Peter, Chris, and Ace Free,
they weren't with them when
they were doing this record,
but it was Paul and Gene
and then the two Erics.
And you're standing there in the studio
where you cut Friends In Low Places,
and there's Gene Simmons
who can't play on a record sitting down.
So he has to stand up and
he's, without the heels,
he's 6'6 anyway, right?
- Really?
Yeah.
- And he's got it way down by his knees,
and he's playing it.
I'm going, this is the
fricking coolest thing.
And they both look great.
But they're both, Paul
Stanley's gotta be 6'4.
You know, Gene has to be 6'5, 6'6.
- And they wear heels!
- And then they get in the heels.
- Yeah.
- That's crazy.
- Because I've been in a picture with them
and I looked like an Oompa Loompa.
- We all do. (laughs)
- Yeah, I was like, not today.
- We all do, they were sweet.
No, I was like, Hey Kiss is coming here,
let's screw everything down
so they can't steal anything.
Right.
(Kelly laughs)
And they came in and
they were the nicest guys
on the planet.
They had baby pictures, all this stuff.
And I tell you anything they
ever wanna do, count me in.
'Cause I love those guys.
- Yeah, I run into them
once with Reba actually.
And they were so nice, they were so cool.
But I was like, really?
You were already tall enough.
You didn't have to wear
those, like I was like.
- So I don't know if
showering with Steven Tyler
might be weirder than I ran
into them with Reba McIntyre.
- No, no, showering with Steven Tyler
definitely tops it all.
- Really?
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
That tops it all.
No, we were at the ACMs,
we were doing the ACMs
and they were there, and
then all of a sudden,
I came out and she was like,
"Kelly, get in the picture."
And I was like, what?
And then, and I was just in a picture
with Kiss and Reba, and I
was like, I love my life,
I was like--
- How cool is that though?
Somebody was thinking,
because I saw those guys
in '81, '80 maybe.
And then I saw 'em in 2010,
2009, something like that.
In the makeup.
- They look the same.
- Pfft, they do, they look exactly--
- You never age, yes.
- No, it's so smart.
- I know.
Okay, that was Rockstar
Roulette, everybody.
Give it up for Garth Brooks!
(audience cheers)
- His Las Vegas residency,
Garth Brooks Plus One
begins tonight at Caesar's
Palace Colosseum in Las Vegas.
You've gotta go see it,
it's an amazing show.
You're gonna love it,
go online for tickets.